alors que le conflit entre la Russie et
l'Ukraine entamait le 24 février 2022 ne
trouve toujours pas d'issue la rédaction
de TV tour a décidé de lui consacrer une
série de reportages toute cette semaine
nous allons jeter un coup d'oeil dans le
rétroviseur et revenir sur les
principales actions qui ont marqué le
début de cette guerre il y a un an pour
ce deuxième volet on s'intéresse au tour
en Jau qui sont partis sur place à
porter vivre et matériel c'est le cas
d'un certain bâtisse du Banchet ce
trentenaire a déjà connu pour ses
expéditions écologiques s'est rendu à
trois reprises en Ukraine en 2022 alors
que retient-il de ces séjours en terrain
de guerre notre journaliste Faustine
Luneau est allé à sa rencontre
cela fait 6 mois qu'il est rentré mais
ses souvenirs sont encore très vifs il y
a eu des combats dans ces rues
donc là les Russes il se trouve à
quelques à quelques kilomètres grâce aux
nombreuses vidéos qu'il a tourné
Baptiste Dubanchet peut témoigner de ce
qu'il a vu en Ukraine dès le début du
conflit il est allé là-bas pour aider
les populations locales et évacuer des
familles quelque chose qui m'a marqué
c'est de voir vraiment la solidarité en
Ukraine où les gens en fait s'entraident
on arrivait à deux heures du matin dans
un village on a un coup de téléphone 20
minutes plus tard on avait une maison
qui s'ouvrait avec des plats chauds pour
tout le monde des canapés les gens sont
très très bien organisés en fait pour
pour évacuer partie en voiture de France
il a ramené des Ukrainiens avec lui des
rencontres marquantes pour ce tour en
jeu de 34 ans qui l'ont poussé à
retourner sur place à deux autres
reprises d'abord deux semaines puis deux
mois à chaque fois que je revenais
c'était avec des femmes des enfants mais
en fait en disant au revoir aux et on
savait pas si même eux se poser la
question s'ils allaient revoir à la fois
les femmes les enfants donc oui on y
retourne pour soutenir les gens le
quotidien des maris partis au combat il
l'a vu aussi car Baptiste a pénétré loin
dans le pays jusqu'à zapporija une ville
très proche du front quand on se
déplaçait ouais on est on est à 5 on est
à 5 6 m de distance
pour éviter d'être une cible si on est
tous regroupés forcément ils vont une
fois sur le front où je trouvais qu'on
allait beaucoup trop loin en fait et
c'était ça devenait dangereux il voulait
montrer les Russes aussi enfin me dire
voilà là derrière cet arbre sont des
Russes et ils montraient tout ce que les
Russes avaient fait les garages explosé
les poulailler les maisons où il y avait
des morts il me disait ici il y a tant
de personnes qui sont morts ici enfin il
me montrait tout des images de guerre
qui restent gravées dans sa tête
heureusement aux côtés de souvenirs plus
joyeux la vie elle continue malgré la
guerre quoi donc ouais j'étais invité à
des à des fêtes de naissance à des à des
anniversaires aujourd'hui Baptiste garde
des contacts rentré par manque d'argent
et pour RA ssurer sa famille ses amis
Ukrainiens le tiennent au courant de
l'évolution de la situation sur place
mais ce ne sont pas toujours de bonnes
nouvelles
mon binôme avec qui on livrait la
nourriture et en fait il y a plein de
gens qui livrent plus de nourriture même
lui il galère il y a quelques bâtiments
où on livrait de la nourriture qui ont
été
complètement détruits depuis 6 mois
c'est donc à distance qu'il vit le
conflit mais si la guerre se poursuit
Baptiste n'exclut pas de retourner en
Ukraine